we know that this governments hostile
environment immigration policy is
morally bankrupt we know that because
hundreds of British people who came here
during the Windrush era were being
rounded up threatened denied health care
and even deported
the Home Secretary Sajid Javid vowed to
do whatever it takes to put it right
here's an idea Home Secretary stopped
the callous cruel deportations of
British people that are still going on
you could start with quaky Ida Polie who
has lived here for 26 years since
childhood he was convicted of fraud that
served his sentence for most British
people that would be enough but like
countless others from the Commonwealth
some of whom are married to British
people and have British children Craig
who is being punished a second time by
being deported to Ghana a country he
simply doesn't know we say we value our
relationships of Commonwealth countries
but we still treat the British people
who come from them as second-class
citizens banishing them the moment they
make a mistake this isn't just about
them this is about all of us and what
kind of country we have become for
context and apologies if I mispronounce
a couple of names here but Quaker
adebola was born in Ghana but left when
he was four and as lived here since he
was 12 he was jailed in 2012 after being
found guilty of the UK's biggest fraud
costing his employer UBS 1.8 billion
pounds he was released after serving
half of his seven-year term at about is
now facing deportation as you rightly
said back to garnet is waiting a
judicial review one other case centers
on Hillary in a Mayo Marcus who's facing
a similar case he came to the UK from
Nigeria in 1995 he was 10 he's lived
here ever since
he was granted leave to remain in the
early 2000s but the Home Office now
wants to deport him because he was in
prison in 2013 for a tax offence and
served a custodial term of 15 months
since leaving jail he's become an
ambassador for prison reform that's
background for the viewers what do you
agree that rules are rules
well I agree we've had rules that are
morally in sustain unsustainable and
we've seen that from our government
admitting that its rules are not only
the same are you the same effort who
took part at the start of the show in
the debate went Russia with June you are
I believe
because I'll quote then I wrote it down
we live in a world that's run on a
rules-based system and I'm ugly you
should change the rules of the show we
live in a world that's run on rules by
the end of the show it doesn't say these
two folks and to put it alongside
Windrush is terrible terrible
misrepresentation these people have
committed crimes in wind
is that simply because you came in wind
rush you weren't getting your papers you
that was are you saying that people only
deserve to stay if they had include us
in wind rush is holy enough if we have a
criminal who has served say you know ten
years in prison for murder
or for rape or for defiling a child or a
violent drug dealer who has killed
children by selling drugs do you do you
honestly think that they shouldn't be
deported see because I think they should
be because and I don't buy this argument
that if they're sent back to dangerous
countries they're going to be in trouble
I don't care actually they're making
this country a more dangerous place and
we've got plenty of Danja criminals
enemy it's being being allowed to live
in this country zip it the two instances
you have mentioned the first one I think
the 1.8 billion yes the second one
absolutely not it was a small tax fraud
he was in prison for about 15 months and
then absolutely not
but people Pete you know getting to live
in this country is a privilege if you
come here and you know that the abuse of
that privilege means you're going to be
deported well then if you break the laws
if you heard people if you rape women if
you if you if you heard children you
apps I'm just really truth while you're
bringing in rape and talking about cases
no no well that's what we are talking
about in Carroll they talk about - it is
beautiful in the home the point is that
they're British they're not people who
arrived yesterday they arrived in
childhood they had permanently to remain
they were entitled to British
citizenship and the Home Office's
own review
immigration policy has said it is deeply
disturbing they were entitled to British
citizenship they did not take cash money
for citizenship who would we just
quickly look at some statistics on
deportations
according to home office statistics
twelve thousand three hundred and twenty
one people were deported from the UK
2017 of which five thousand eight
hundred and thirty five were foreign
national offenders ie foreign national
offenders but what when the phone of the
Home Office was asked about this they
said that you know you had to take each
case on a case-by-case basis and
low-risk offenders should not
necessarily be turfed out if they had
lived here all their lives into which
category I think lots of these people
must fall and so I think Afra has a
point they did not know aged four that
if they committed a crime in the course
of their lives they would be thrown out
of the country vacated that you should
can I add to the conversation so after I
completely agree with you as you know I
signed the petition supporting quake ooh
I think the way he has been treated
throughout this whole case is and if
we're honest actually is completely
unfair because I don't believe that a
junior trader could have made all of
those trades without somebody signing on
when he was convicted he was acquitted
on any counts of personal gain okay all
right so you don't want to go there well
then the second piece is this is part of
sadly like you say the hostile
environment this is part of this
government trying to manipulate the
immigration figures because what we are
having is we are having deportation
buses waiting at prisons to take people
home the same is happening in America
and actually it's about our values it's
about do we it's about who we it's about
who would never say it's about who we
say we are if we're saying somebody is a
British citizen we're saying somebody is
British and they have committed a crime
that's the whole point
well he was entitled to it there are a
lot of people who do the works as the
major to entitle it just isn't Morrises
people anyone sentenced to four years or
more in jail it is in the British public
interest to have them deported and
that's fair because if you're sentenced
to four years for something you've done
something pretty paid below this person
the biggest-ever
fraud in this country not British
nationals are just exploring Rachel's
foreign-born it didn't take didn't
actually do it a lot of them didn't that
was because they had children it didn't
occur yes but there's Britishness would
be called in question I believe a
British in all but paper and that's why
the shore of you said it is deeply
troubling to deport people here since
childhood because Quaker taking him as
an example is the product of British
education you went to school in
University here he worked for a company
here he says that the reason he made
this mistake which he's owned up to and
now he works in schools as a reformer
services are trying to improve the
system was because of a misplaced
pressure and loyalty to his institution
he is not regarded as somebody who's
tried to improve the society and he's
now facing deportation to a country he
doesn't know how is that in line with
the country that has committed serious
crimes
from Stephen Shaw who is the former
prisons Ombudsman and he said I find the
policy of removing individuals brought
up here from infancy to be deeply
troubling for low-risk offenders it
seems entirely disproportionate to tear
them away from their lives families and
friends in the UK and to send them to
countries where they may not speak the
language or have any
that Home Office should no longer
routinely seek to remove those who were
born in the UK or have been brought up
here from an early age and a lot of them
have been born here that's the other
thing there were people who didn't
process I just let me read this home
over sin because important you having
mentioned that now all foreign nationals
who are given a custodial sentence will
be considered for removal and any
foreign criminal who is sentenced to 12
months or more imprisonment must
automatically be subject to a
deportation order under the UK Borders
Act of 2007 foreign nationals who abused
our hospitality by committing crimes in
the UK should be in no Doubt's as the
Home Office of our determination to
deport them and we have removed more
than 44,000 500 foreign offenders since
2010 but the point is I think costing
someone who's been here since childhood
as a foreign national abusing our
hospitality and I just want to read you
a quote from Hilary and Naomi Marcus
who's the other person we were
mentioning who's married his children he
has benefits he was ten he says the
whole ordeal has been terrifying I've
been stressed out
anxious deflated edgy and depressed the
thoughts have been kicked out of a
country I've known as home since my
formative years the person I am today is
because of the environment I grew up in
in this country the system is unfair
because it does not take the individuals
contributions to society into
consideration just coming back to your
point Nick about a rules-based system
which as you know as a former lawyer I'm
the first person to defend living under
a rules-based system the point is that
the rules should have discretion to take
in circumstance individual cases other
ways you end up with injustice the two
cases I've mentioned and there are many
more like them are people who present
little or no risk who have served their
sentence who are trying to make this a
better country now having made a mistake
and have family friends and deep tide
here and no others for going wrong it's
just weak them you gotta go but before
we do there's just time for this now
even if you don't watch strictly
distraught to miss the news this week
that comedian Shaun double-end Walsh or
though the Contessa's was called kissing
his dance partner Katya Jones both Walsh
and Jones were in long-term
relationships with other people and both
issued public apologies but it was a
response of Rebecca Humphreys washes
girlfriend that caught the eye of many
people she said quote this whole
business
has served to remind me that I am strong
capable person who is now free and no
victim I have a voice and will use it by
saying this to any woman out there who
deep down feels worthless and trapped
with a man they love believe in yourself
and your instincts it's important also
to recognize that in these situations
those who hold power over you are
insecure and fragile and the need for
control comes from a place of
vulnerability despite everything I hope
he shown with a double in gets what he
wants from this but she says but I'm not
sorry I took the cat for that miss
Humphreys you are certainly a straight
talker of a weak disgust I remember when
my very first live-in relationship broke
not talking about the cat and she took
two things the cooker and the bloodhound
my blood and the cooker